bonjour comment allez vous moi ça va
très bien regardez qu'est ce qui se
passe tricot veut des caresses sont
allés là il est tout mignon depuis
thaler et la panne le sni fait mais il
va falloir avancer souvenez vous on
avait fait des débuts total wipeout un
finalement on avait eu chaud au cul on
avait atterri ici donc on va voir où ça
nous mène tout simplement et je fais
toujours une fixation sur le deuxième
trio qu'on a pu l'apercevoir mon gars je
m'en vais pas voilà j'ai envie de savoir
à énigmes on commence tout les kings
j'ai envie de savoir qui il est et
pourquoi il est là à merveille la même
merde [ __ ] ya un navire est combien le
trio à asher qui faisaient ça me fait
trop mal à retrouver samy el madrigal
toi mon gars légal twh et de monter
dessus comme ça je serai à l'abri à la
queue au plat c'est avoir pris la tacc
fois à parce que y'a le il ya cinq blocs
d'accord ok c'est pour ça qu'il
n'attaquera pas du coup laissé approcher
vous saviez approche toi ami sont
bloqués ils peuvent pas monter d'accord
donc à mon avis j'ai le tour du truc à
faire pour aller décrocher le truc là
haut et permettent à tricot d' aller
défoncer cvn d'armure aubin écoute on va
aller voir battant dessus oh le coup on
va essayer d'aller voir là bas mais pas
qu'à 3 de relever non là il abuse sept
enfants abusent munitions pas de pc soir
mon gars
time enchaîne trop je n'arrivais pas à
m'en sortir oh il l'avait jamais fait ça
c'est les gardes qu'il ouvre cette
[ __ ] de portes mais regardez tous les
sorts qu'ils envoient quoi l asie mais
oh [ __ ] tient matar ya si les feintes
et yes alors ça doit être réparé par là
là c'est bon regarder fallait juste
atteindre cet endroit et là on peut
escalader up allez vas-y de pêche toi
petit coup la pression
ok ils savent pas ils savent pas sauter
c'est un avantage alors faut grimper
lathus ça on attend tricot il est là bas
leinders ouais y'a de la bouffe et
aériens juste des grilles à ça que je
peux saisir ça sert à quoi ça ouvre la
grille
oh ça fait quelque chose je sais pas
trop quoi mais à ça permet d'accéder à
autre quand vers ben voilà la veille un
rebord la waho au [ __ ] c'est très
casse était incollable
yes au [ __ ] j'y croyais plus je n'y
croyais pas
donc là en bas les armures elles sont en
pls parce que je vais pouvoir faire
tomber cette merde cette saloperie qui
fait peur à mon tricot
voilà
allez tricot ça toi tu veux mon gars il
va aider mot dire et ben voilà
et ben voilà on en parle alors qu'on a
fait pendant qu'ils ne démontrent pas
aller lui chercher son bail le beaufort
tiens voilà qui va te calmer alors à mon
avis il faut être l'autre côté je paye
alors sautant moi je pense voilà on
équilibre la salle est tendue mais un
moyen je pense au pire tu m'attends dans
ta bouche comme tafer d'avant là que
nous voilà sur des rails
ok j'ai réussi alors où
ah [ __ ] tricot il va être fâché il va
être fâché il ya des choses qui ne
l'aiment pas alors là bas je voulais
marche dont je pense qu'il va falloir
aller là bas mais il ya ce truc là en
plein milieu à toi mais comment je sens
et accèder à ça là haut est une
passerelle
ouais ça doit être ça ouais ok faut
atteindre la passerelle là-haut via la
chaîne qui est là via attendant me sers
des gardes ok donc à mon avis il faut
aller là dessus déjà mais là dessus
c'est trop long je peux pas y aller seul
le tricor faut que tu viennes tu peux
venir ou pas qui sifflent 30 minutes de
galère plus tard car squeeze et très
très con ok de retour sur les rails
[ __ ] c'était très compliqué jeu pour
aller en fait je juge hyper qu on fait
juste aller là et lui ouvrir tout
bêtement tout bêtement l on prend aura
baisse
royal où au [ __ ] je fais mourir
maintenant tu prends ta bouffe avant je
mangerais bien
il est très très bien à les participants
il va me suis naturellement choisissent
un pot de colle un techo 1 c'est un
animal très très fidèle la chose qui va
me suivre
j'avais des doutes sa fidélité là nous
voici donc dans ce nouvel endroit
donc je pense que de base à mon avis le
tout cas faire là ce sera de monter là
haut et de faire un saut sur la cage
mais oui mon grand il est grand la il
est loin des gros tu vas devoir te
mettre debout contre ça ouais vas-y tu
l'as vu hier
en plus il ya de la bouffe tu vois je
porterai galets euh oui fait sens pour y
prendre le risque
tu veux la bouffe tiens mon gars bah
fallait l'attrapeur plein air allez
mange ça met toi bien moi je veux voir
comment on peut faire
il n'y a pas une chaîne en or il faut
que je sorte un mais oui on va sortir
allez faut que j'y aille j'ai positionné
ok la grille logiquement on peut
s'accrocher il me fait peur
ce gamin me terrifie mon gars dans ses
mouvements j'ai peur qu'ils tombent
ainsi une fois qu'on est là il ya une
chaîne qui est là qui va sûrement se
balancer une union tout ça me ça fait
partout
il faut repasser de plus c'est bon
qu'est la chaîne d'en face là on va
descendre au [ __ ] la veille avoir un
truc d'équilibrage rsa va être l'enfer
ça va être l'enfer si je me fois on est
mort c'est simple si je me forme beurre
ok go j'arrive à la notion de distance
aujourd'hui j'ai peur à chaque fois il
est outil qu il est là bas il va bien ok
me regarde il est mignon mais les
millions pour le dira jamais assez
allez on va faire tomber le l'objet et
tu sera libéré délivrait alors on
atterri là qu'est
peut être l'autre côté je suppose hop là
il ya des morceaux on peut s'y prendre
un bruit et le mec est trop fort
discrète il ya 28 malades
clairement il a pratiqué il faut se
mettre debout dessus et ça facilite
grandement les choses y'avait du couffo
s'arrête du tout passé de l'autre côté
en fait ok et ben merci à la mort vous
art permet découvert ça j'ai peur de ouf
ok ok je vois que les suspects soient
hop là on va se mettre debout là dessus
et accèder à lautoka tatry qu il ait pas
sur un bon gars il était mon passera il
encore moins serein que nous quand on le
voit se battent quoi ok et là je vais
repasser de l'autre côté dans le trou ça
j'ai pas vu trou du tout juste avant je
suis vraiment pas en forme aujourd'hui
[ __ ] je suis là en arrivant aux up &
on va pouvoir faut le détacher à d'avoir
un délire avec le mécanisme derrière ça
là je vais aller dessus ça faire
contrepoint un truc du genre c'est pas
ça moi je pense qu'il faut sauter en
face voilà je pas trop réfléchi à cette
option
pourquoi voir tout de suite ça marche
c'est assez chaud là on va jouer à
l'équilibriste mon gars mais ça va le
faire on monte up on a atteint le
premier obtient ses shows par contre on
est et on n'a jamais été aussi haut et
loin du dédain bord en fait saquer
stressant et éco osciller en pls total
on continue d'escaladé figurez vous
c'est incroyable je pense qu'on en
arrive là édition à part décroché le
truc a mon avis oui on regarde et on va
le pousser ses affaires un bordel
monstre même mec c'est sûr et certain on
va on va tomber c'est sûr y'a pas de
ah non c'est bon eux non c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon ça change pas l'équipe
ok on est bons temps on casse tout mon
gars et là il me rejoint comme un tricot
ça la question et il ya des piliers ok
il veille sur les piliers lui en bas il
ya un petit piqué la voix elle a fait le
grand saut direct des corps je suis là à
monaco ses bienfaits [ __ ] je crois
vraiment que je m'étais juste poiré
[Musique]
merci mon grand j'adore ta queue il est
idiot il me regarde derrière ça que
tranquillement donc enfin tu tourne et
qu'on aille de l'autre côté mon gars
voilà et là tu sautes latu job au [ __ ]
est mais heureusement qui s'est musclé
les la poigne hearst enfants ok là où tu
peux monter ou encore dernier tu peux le
faire je le sais c'est pas genre pièce
aya miroir alors attends bouge pas
j'avais oublié ta petite phobies et ce
autant voilà parfait bourse pas très
stable si savoir alors ce truc on le
prend et on le pousse à tanger peut
repartir avec j'ai vraiment pas repartir
avec
allez dégage savez gage hop là asie
vient à faut que je dégage des bouts de
verre comme ça aussi ça d'un tricot fait
pas ça
oh non ça ce fait la gueule entre
l'entourage 18
ok je suis sûr thouaré 0 [ __ ] s'était
rapidement gare caucheteux là j'irai
mais moi je peux plus là je vais pas les
capacités est optionnel
ok on est bien on est bien on est bien
on est bien et ben mec faisant atteindre
le pot 1 tchèque on n'a pas le choix je
travaille discrètement du cul de tricot
là il ya des trucs pour descendre si si
je pense que c'est pas la prairie les a
pas mis fin à ça qu elle m'amène pile là
où il faut ouais bouge pas trop bas
contre sens je vais vraiment foire est
tombé dans le vide ok on est bon donc là
ensuite je remonte par là mais non si
c'est bon je remonte par là il faut que
je passe te faut que j'adhère écoutez
moi même et que le motive avec de la
bouffe je veux pas faire ton somme a
ajouté qu on prend des risques mais je
pense vraiment qu'il va falloir qu'on
aille près d'un câble pour traverser en
fait
c'est sûr
voix
ok et maintenant qu'on est là qu'on peut
monter à gauche le ya de l'air vont
s'éclater merci non plus et on atteint
une petite cinématique
j'arrive j'arrive [ __ ] il doit pas
être confort dans cette langue j'ai fait
une grosse connerie est donc c'était en
japonais
quand la buav parler j'ai l'impression
que c'est le japonais ce qui prouve que
je ne parle pas du tout japonais du coup
en fait dans cette langue qui créé pour
le jeu c'est ouf
il faut enlever le travail de recherche
et écrivain de l'ombre à 10 août
bon il veut pas sauter voilà alors on
avait du coup dans un nouvel endroit on
fait tout repart l'intérieur c'est ça
ouais j'espère que rappaz d'armée xxi
bien sûr ce qu'en disent accueil va
falloir être très vite n'y a pas de
secret rapport est très très vite c'est
tout voilà
quoi mais elle va se faire engueuler par
son boss avec l'armure ils sont pas du
tout dans ses buts et voilà objets petit
esquive ce qui m'a poussée dans le vide
je suis choquée mon gabarit il prend il
tombe elle l'a dans l'eure dans leur bus
cabano elle pousse dans le vide
calmement faut que parce qu avec sa faux
que j'ai un bon milieu hockey viol au
hockey j'ai réussi alors et au milieu
qu'est ce qu'on a un levier parfait qui
va ouvrir la grille qui avait là haut je
suppose ok même rugby et merde il a
trouvé des patrons allez c'est parti on
y retourne pour un tour enfin que
j'esquive attention pro esquive up là
haut
ils avaient peur à voir carte sis à côté
de monsieur qu à deux feux je fais quoi
là ah [ __ ] je fais tomber ok je
redescends je m'aime pas je vais
atterrir fallait que je monte c'est ça
avec le monde dont j'avais une chance
sur deux jeux permet dit c'est bon je
pense qu'on va monter à l'éviter pas ken
green on aille elle porte des gardiens
de but à quand un gardien
cholet a du coup il ya une porte donc
c'est si beau l asim attrapant bougera
pas tant de me libérer me foutrait dans
la porte et 1,91 sérieux de l'ouche
pascal oger bas la vie mais que fait le
saut de l'ange m'en bats les couilles en
mode assassin's creed beach mais on est
bon
c'est fait
ok 5 portes qui s'ouvrent statuera pas
encore plus d'armure derrière mes petits
pas hop
oh [ __ ] ils sont là ce qui est je
crois qu'il y en a un qui est resté en
salle alors c'est bon et bah écoutes je
peux me garer tranquillement
ils m'envoient des sorts ça avoir des
plus aisés défense anciens s'étaient pas
peur mais pas avant d'avoir peur mon
gars allez vas-y il te suivent
ok y'a ti coq est pas loin ok il doit
être en dessous moi c'est comme ça qu'on
a accès de l'autre côté d'accord je ne
sais que tu es par un câble banon ok
j'ai compris je compris je vais pas
chercher trop loin c'est tendu la coke
et juste en dessous il s'y prend déjà
flou mais non le temps que je mets à
l'est l'autre côté je prends des
javelots [ __ ] non au nom les [ __ ]
j'espère qu'ils vont pas tuer j'espère
qu'ils vont pas tuer aller
alors on y va allez vas-y on y va j'ai
besoin tournée tricot tissage à bien
tourner aide j'ai besoin de ton aide si
tu fais un pas je meurs
[Musique]
je te retire les pieux résidus passante
passe tu passes tu passes des années
cherchait les vieux je pense qu'il a du
mal parce qu'il a mal quand je retiens
et pio
ok il est sur les autres sur les autres
la tornade hot
donnant corps à la
c'est pour tirer tricot
j'arrive au gréement grange mais de
l'autre côté je vais t'aider à vélo mais
de l'autre côté moi je peux y aller je
peux aller j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais
j'y vais j'y vais je pensais que va être
retiré les pionniers en sus que tu peux
pas en fait le fils plantes ya par
levier un truc là le levier juste la
matinée cacher j'avais pas vu [ __ ]
[ __ ] je pratique mon gars je vois
tricot pas vierge pas bien moi à l'asie
tu viens maintenant tu peux venir mon
gars allez on est libéré on continue on
a fait un tricot sur ce court n'a
vraiment failli perdre illico mon gaz
chaud
est-ce qu'on va retrouver le miroir je
me demande mais ça va à tricot tu t'en
derby mon gars y'a un levier ici ça fait
qu'attirer ça
aucune autre issue doux autonome à huis
clos à nice
autre icône ya la photo khouya tout doux
à tous ali et yak akon
tu m'étonnes est comment il a dû forcer
sur ses bras va ton mec c'est par là
gros molosse voilà l anp molosses et la
gagnera peut-être de la bouffe ou des
gardes
on sait pas encore on va bien trouver la
bofi ses emmerdes j'étais destiné à
tomber pas se mentir et les papillons
j'ai raté de la bouffe et des papillons
là à voile a très bien ça hein
maintenant je suis carrément celui là
comment je fais et si en fait je monte
là et je l'envoie là bas le truc
voilà maintenant on a battu ans d'abord
contre n'importe quoi mais a profité
ah oui mais non et comment
[Musique]
non tu te coincer dans le couple mais
[ __ ] oui la caméra avait dit bon mois
gens qui t'aiment soulte est lancé enfin
mon gars enfin c'est la fiesta loca on
va récupérer la tombe pas ton passé bros
[ __ ] j'ai tellement peur qu'ils
tombent et l'a logiquement on peut se
barrer et on l'a bien mérité me direz
vous j'approuve geyrhalter qu en tant qu
ils aient le temps de mourir 200 fois de
fin mon gars au [ __ ] j'ai désole erik
elle a vu la bouffe
il a l'oeil l'animal qui a vu la bouffe
tient aux bottes aux plats fait du bien
à ça se porte bien à quoi on est mieux
là et on se lève carrément c'est parfait
montre qu ils sautent de joie alors que
tu es mon gars donc ce truc là je pense
qu'on peut le ballon mais ça bougeait
pas ça pas bougé presse abu jamal à
hockey dans ce qu'il y en avait deux qui
étaient collés l'un à l'autre d'accord
tu vas pas mourir écrasé par un chariot
quand même c'est bon on y est qu'est ce
que ça ouvre sa qu'est-ce que ça ouvre
elle va montrer je pense à ça ou la
porte qu'elle abat tricot et bien du
coup ait pu choquer super
merci quico nous voilà maintenant fermé
tous les deux ici qu'est ce qu'on fout
ah si peut-être à gauche l'attendait
peut-être qu'ici c'est forcément par là
y'a qu'un chemin c'est forcément par là
haut ou d'accords lampe torche des yeux
qu'on des lampes torches pas dit qu'elle
va tu vas venir mon gars tu as mais
claire est clair moi cet endroit qu'est
ce qu'on a
ok j avance continu continu continu tu
me dis qu'un chemin la loi est par là
non là au delà ou par contrainte y avoir
un truc
ah ouais là haut tout là haut mais qu
hockey vas-y let's go ja oui d'accord
avec carbon fait plus que tout est
debout et ben on est bien le ballon il
faut sortir un épatant de solutions ok
vas-y ouais merci le biceps
et c'est là que tu m'abandonnes parce
qu'un miroir et tu te suis dessus c'est
ça qu'est ce que je peux faire ici non
mais non la deuxième bête
et puis il ya deuxième bête mais qu elle
a vu la ville soit à faire il a vu tout
seul il est très malin vas-y mon genre
de jeu si le deuxième thé causé une meuf
la tendance à tulle ac du monde elle est
toute émue hockey à droite maintenant
vas tu vas tu as compris tout seul à mon
avis il faut que je ok parfait au [ __ ]
je suis allé au culot mon gars je
m'attendais pas à un résultat 6e dans
cette fois j'y vais en moins de prudence
prudence extrême mais c'est vraiment ça
à mon avis il faut vraiment marcher en
équipe surtout que puisqu'on me sourire
d il ya de l'herbe là-bas pour
s'accrocher montée il à lorient hop la
pop hutin on va y aller tout doute r je
fais le bourrin il faut vraiment y aller
tout doucement ce le dernier tout doux
voilà que besoin par la passerelle et on
est en équilibre n'est pas bien là on
n'est pas bien [ __ ] voilà c'était le
g8 ya un deuxième truc envers juste
derrière plus à l est qu à ses fans ses
volontés arrivé pourquoi tu mets la
pression
ok allez on y va aucun autre côté tricot
tati cauet blocks j'espère qu'à la fin
du jeu on saura bah je sais pas si je
pense qu'il y aura la voix off qui nous
le dira mais on sera pour quoi il a peur
de ça qui sont les espèces de mecs en
armure et c'est quoi on va devoir
marcher sur le deuxième c'est ça ouais
ok on y va parce qu'il ya des gens qui
vont sur les même tatouage du coup bas
caso suis là je les fais parce que j'ai
vu que le petit garçon de guardian avait
un crâne tatoué sur c'est trop long
doit-on paix l'amour bas les couilles
bah ouais tu reviens pour régler tout
proche de moi chaque fois toi
ok bah écoutez on entend atteindre le
sommet de la [ __ ] c'est vachement au
monga up hockey encore un [ __ ] à oui
mais là ce qui nous mène directement au
à l'élément perturbateur alors vas-y je
vais pousser [ __ ] mais il faut
vraiment franchement si tu bats tu es tu
as peur tricot tu as tu saignes partout
on peut obliger à poster leurs étoiles
mais si tu bats tu es un petit peu tu as
peur tu ne ferais rien est tellement de
temps mais tellement tricot et surtout
tu voudrais prendre tellement moins de
risques à chaque fois j'ai peur que tout
se pète la gueule ans
voila voila quand je parle de risque tu
vois c'est exactement de ça que je parle
c'est ça c'est parti au plat sur le
museau direct [ __ ] beau gastrique or
là ce que tu nous fais moi le petit
robot il est pour toi tu l'as vu bien au
top il ya démarche à faire pas pour
aller péter un autre miroir je crois que
j'ai vu déjà sur toi mon club puisque tu
peux c'est moi qui fais c'est nickel oh
ça va ça va ça et là y'a de miroirs qui
va tout bloquer ah bah je vais y aller
en mode
ah oui bah oui l'espoir faire sur moi
qui m'y colle toute manière on a compris
bon j'avoue les armures ceux qui s'y
colle et vas-y su les mettre face il a
pété en plus d'être co et ouais mon gars
c'est savoir un corps d'enfant dans la
vallée je vais faire pareil
allez on y va ça dégage dit betty
emblème par sa mère à sa mère tricot
tricot
elle moi je vais je peux rien faire et
moi je fais ton patricot si vous au quai
d'accord ayvaz en bas pour moi ces
passionnés ok faut que je me lâche
hockey aux jeux pensait pas sa possible
que sa foi ok ce parti à l'été suez
reproche la vas-y à cette fois il m'a eu
oh [ __ ] on n'était pas loin de la mort
la can tricorps ça va tout avec notre
coeur comme ça
[ __ ]
car sa sortie toujours la queue qui est
là pour nous sauver on aime c'est que on
l'a précis on lui fait des pis y'a plus
miroir tu nous fais qui fait maintenant
tiko basé sur de cette fois je suis
accroché voilà accroche toi tout renfort
la [ __ ] t'as plus tôt puisque tu t'es
mange et à leur fallait que ça arrive tu
vas dire vrai que ça arrive
ok c'est bon au [ __ ] tu me fais peur
comme le cerveau et la france avaient
pattes avant oui
yes allez encore un peu de chemin on est
bon et on peut accéder à une grille là
bas c'est ça je suppose ouais ok [ __ ]
[ __ ] je te laisse geremek
et ça m'a fait tellement mal au coeur de
voir tricot tomber comme ça mais qu elle
voit les hommes il ya pas de cette
quatrième vidéo sur the last guardian
espère qu'elle vous a plu ainsi que
toutes les autres n'hésitez pas à aller
mais c'est le cas ça me fera très
plaisir je pense qu'on en saura plus
très rapidement à du prochain épisode là
je vais la boulangerie ensuite sur le
prochain c'est obligé là bas je suis
impatient à la prudence chez nova
savoyarde et portez vous bien sûr à tout
le monde
pis
[Musique]